[creator] Okay, that was like so fast
[creator] So I asked it what was next god, I need to fix this bug
[creator] I'm like trying to move things around and then it moves other things and it's really weird annoying
[creator] I was like, all right, what's next?
[creator] and
[creator] Anyway, so we're on the build stage now, so
[creator] It's gonna go ahead and allow all of these to
[creator] to run free and we're gonna see what happens.
[creator] Create a new canvas called build.
[creator] Now move all of the build agents to the build canvas.
[creator] Awesome.
[creator] So we're gonna call this canvas plan.
[creator] All right, so we got our two planning agents here
[creator] that did everything, cool.
[creator] See, this is so annoying, why is this happening?
[creator] Tidy.
[creator] Yeah, we'll go with that.
[creator] All right, so we got a renderer and VFX agent, a core engine agent, stages and choices agent,
[creator] and a HUD and screens agent.
[creator] So I got these running, the dog sibling grunches, I'll read them, blah, blah, blah, blah, okay,
[creator] core engine, yeah, they're probably all doing the same thing, they are, okay, so I'll be
[creator] when I have something new worth sharing.